also sprach sich angelique ist wird zur
gewalt aufgerufen wie hast du das gefühl
ist jetzt momentan die stimmung kann man
sich schon als aufgeheizt beschreiben im
moment kann ich noch nicht sagen dass
die stimmung aufgeheizt ist die leute
sind jetzt erst auf den weg zu den
demonstrationen zu der
auftaktveranstaltung hier vor dem
brandenburger tor auf der anderen seite
sieht es vielleicht ganz anders aus aber
hier ist man noch friedlich hier wird
man natürlich blöd angeguckt wenn man
die maske trägt man kommt sich fast
schon wie ein fremdkörper vor
also ich kann sagen an die hygieneregeln
wird sich hier auf keinen fall gehalten
was ich gesehen haben wird sich hier
küsschen gegeben da wird sich umarmt da
wird sich die hand gegeben also von
hygienemaßnahmen keine spur und das ist
nämlich auch der grund warum die leute
hier auf die straße gehen heute weil sie
keine lust haben auf diese maßnahmen und
es wird auch ganz klar dazu aufgerufen
sich nicht an die hygienemaßnahmen zu
halten
wie schätzt du das ja sehr gerne auch
mal einen kleinen schwenk wir wollen uns
ansehen wie es vor ort aussieht
das heißt diese bilder mal ausrücken
[Musik]
ja hier marschieren wahnsinnig
wahnsinnig viel menschen jetzt aufs
brandenburger tor zu hier soll die
auftaktveranstaltung statt finden und so
sieht es hier aus bisher